have you ever wondered what a man would
look like if his entire body were
painted purple I know I haven't but for
those of you who have today is your
lucky day a user could liquid fire has
challenged me to paint my entire body
purple so I have some purple body paint
I have some purple hair spray and I have
some purple boxer shorts and so without
further ado here is me but slightly more
purple will not slightly more purple
100% more purple ready okay
hello challenge completed booyah
purple man I don't really know what to
say I just can't stop looking at myself
in the little one of the thingy do you
like it because I quite like it I think
I might I don't know take myself purple
from now until the end of forever
I am the purple man I'm the purple man
that is what they call me because that
is why the purple purple
what does a man do he comes and looks at
you with his big blue eyes it's really
good purple - and that is what he do be
purple with you until you leave I
totally care about that song off the top
of my head I'm really proud of it good
mom um come okay this is my mother she's
not purple she's just normal colored how
do you feel about the fact you've given
birth to a purple son a bit concerned
concerned yeah how many people spend
their evenings painting their sons
purple only the coolest people maybe the
curly the coolest people it could only
happen in our household it took me about
half an hour to do this and I needed my
mum's help and it was it was so worth it
if they was so worth it the challenge
was just for me to paint my entire body
purple but I was kind of tempted that
once I would be purple I would go out
into the streets of bath and just kind
of dance around as a purple man that
didn't happen it would have been too
cold
it was a cool idea at least if you won't
come on camera at least just tell me
what you think my teeth look really
white this is correct and your eyes
actually look slightly green they do a
little bit yeah
they look very green actually yeah why
is that because I'm hopeful obviously
everything changes when a man becomes
purple if you want purple which color
would you like to be just normal
coloured its normal color purple is what
I am
[Music]
mum how much did all this purple stuff
cost and all together it cost 19 pounds
19 quite a lot of purple buddy dye left
over so if anybody needs any purple if
anyone wants to follow me they'd make a
video response of you painting yourself
purple we've got lots of purple paint
but you can borrow I actually think that
Charlie looks a bit like a Ribena grape
a Ribena grey a Ribena grape hey Charlie
yeah do you think it was a good idea to
paint yourself purple no really I agree
goodbye you know what they say about
purple men they bleed purple blood